the United States Secret Service the
protocols are born out of blood
it may seem dramatic but it's actually a
necessary process to understand past
incidents failures and successes to
ensure that threats are fully mitigated
for future protectees
my name is Jonathan wacko I spent 14
years in the u.s. Secret Service as a
special agent they joined the United
States Secret Service just prior to 9/11
I was assigned to the New York field
office as a criminal investigator and
2008 went to Washington DC where I was
assigned to the Secretary of Homeland
Security's detail then just after the
election of President Obama I went to
the president's detail which allowed me
the opportunity to plan and coordinate
trips both domestically and abroad for
the president and first lady
so the approach of the Secret Service
takes is a very proactive advanced
process we think about three main areas
we think about what are we gonna do in a
tactical or crisis situation what are we
gonna do in a medical situation and what
are we gonna do if we have to relocate
this protectee and those are the big
three there are subcategories to all of
them but every agent and officer is
constantly thinking about what am I
going to do what is my personal
protection plan and what is my plan for
my protectee
we've never complacent because the
moment that we become complacent
complacency kills and something happens
the president goes to any location the
methodology is to set up concentric
rings of protection around where he's
going to be that starts with the inside
of a building the dais if he's giving a
speech how do we build out a security
program from there first we look at
where the president is going to stand we
try to mitigate any line-of-sight issues
that may occur we want to make sure that
that environment is secure I want to be
able to fortify my perimeter I want
access control I want to fully
understand how I mitigate everybody
that's coming into that environment
that's the metal detectors that's the
explosive detection that is the
utilization of different technology to
ensure that we're always putting the
president in the most safe location
regardless of where it is when a Secret
Service advance agent goes into a
location that the president or any of
our other protectors are going to go
into they're looking at that space much
differently than the average citizen
everything from the HVAC the air
conditioning units you know how does
that affect my environment
can someone introduce an error
all spray from a clean air intake from
the outside and affect myself or the
protectee I'm looking at the lighting
who controls it can that room get dark
real fast and then attack it launched
how many entrances are there is there a
set of stairs that can lead up from a
basement is there an access way into the
kitchen area I want to understand all of
the access points into that location
once that room fills up with people I
want to understand what are the crowd
dynamics gonna be in that space in the
event that something happens it could be
something in administrative like a
medical emergency how is that crowd
gonna react what are they going to do
and what that crowd is going to do is
going to be the opposite to what I'm
going to do with my protectee because I
want to be able to quickly and
effectively remove myself from that
situation once that environment is
established how do we maintain it the
entire duration that the president's
there I'm looking at the perimeter of
that location that perimeter can be our
local law enforcement presence that's
now allowing us to keep the general
public away from this protective site
that moves out even further we start
looking at long-range issues that I need
to address
I need aerial surveillance I need the
ability to understand what that airspace
looks like above me I need to understand
if I'm near a terrain features such as
water how do I mitigate the
vulnerability that's coming from that
waterway so do I need police boats out
there that starts to become that outer
ring so protective methodology and these
concentric rings you want to address
those types of threats as far out as
possible that's really the tradecraft
and it comes down to experience it comes
down to constant training and
communication and awareness of your
environment oftentimes people look at
the President and they have blinders on
they don't even realize that their own
action of what they're doing around the
present here we see a young woman who
starts hugging the president and doesn't
let go she's not doing that out of
malice she's just starstruck that the
president is there the Secret Service
has to be mindful that this isn't a
threat that's going to take the
president's life but it is nettlesome we
have to address this because it can
cause a safety issue in the operating
environment for the president a lot of
times the actions that see
service agents take are not even
realized by the people in the crowd here
we see a special agent in charge and
other agents carefully removing the arm
of the individual away from the
president the president doesn't realize
what's happening nor does the individual
but this is tradecraft this is what they
trained for and it happens right here or
seeing here is then candidate Trump
speaking someone aggressively comes
towards the podium Secret Service agent
is immediately up onto the stage the
shift comes up with them they provide
360 degrees of cover once the threat is
taken away the president can go back to
you know giving his his speech so as
dynamically as a threat Rises they can
also be mitigated just as fast social
media is just instant information and it
can be factual or disinformation that
social media is a challenge for any
protective construct whether it's the
Secret Service any government entity or
in private security because information
is dispersed and can go viral very
quickly there are times that the Secret
Service in conjunction with the military
and the White House take the president
on a classified trip previously that
action was much easier we can go under
the cover of darkness we could deploy a
low profile protective methodology where
we're not going around with lights and
sirens and a big police motorcade
problem with social media today is
everything becomes public so the example
of the president going over to Iraq the
disclosure of that became public when
Air Force One was seen over the United
Kingdom and someone took a picture of it
posted it online and instantaneously
every news service around the world
realized the president was in the air
and in trying to track that aircraft
becomes easier and now we have the
president's location on a classified
mission and just think about how
dangerous that is for the United States
Secret Service the military and the
President himself social media is a
challenge not for just understanding
where our protectees are it's also a new
pathway for threats and social media has
become this superhighway for making
threats against protectees but every
threat that comes into the Secret
Service has to be investigated the
pathway of social media doesn't change
that because now a message is come in
every
that are either direct or veiled threats
that have to be investigated the same
way the means opportunity intent for
someone to need to cause harm to our
protectee the threat environment is very
dynamic and unpredictable Secret Service
is mindful of that so we have to
constantly look back and say how do we
improve how do we get better
yes we came out of that environment
nothing happened but is there something
that we could have done better if you
look back at the Kennedy assassination
no one had thought that someone would
try to shoot the president from a long
range as they were traveling in a
motorcade think about how difficult that
shot is to make it's a moving target
it's small from a distance so in the
Secret Service at that time was looking
at it they're always mindful that there
is a probability that an event like that
could happen but the likelihood was
pretty small for that high-impact
situation well calculation was wrong so
on this day in Dallas we saw some things
that worked really well we saw that
Secret Service agents that are located
here and here are able to quickly react
to anything that may affect the the
President or the first lady what's
different here this time as compared to
today is the motorcade route itself how
it's secured back then on either side of
the motorcade as you'll see the crowd
can get very close so at any moment
someone could step into the crowd and
block that motorcade today based upon
what we know we ensure that all
presidential motorcades have some sort
of barrier and are posted by law
enforcement to ensure that threats can't
come and cross across in front of the
motorcade
additionally what we're seeing in this
angle is is a great view of the
president first lady you'll never see
that today why because after this tragic
day in American history
The Secret Service learned a very vital
lesson never to allow the president
United States to ride in an open air
vehicle the Secret Service would rather
have the president in an armored vehicle
away from the public where they're not
engaging thus reducing the risk however
that's just not feasible in today's
environment so what we have to do is we
have to stage engagement between the
president and the public very carefully
here we see a video of President Obama
from the inauguration getting out of
this limo this is a carefully
coordinated event we have had a very
specific security construct built around
it to ensure even though they are in
open air and in the public all threats
within all concentric rings been
mitigated our protective methodology
hasn't changed we're providing 360
degrees of coverage we're seeing the
crowds are completely separated by
barricades so we will not have a surge
onto the motorcade route there's also
police postings here here here every 7
feet there was another member of the law
enforcement or military community that
was providing security for this event
every agent in this image has a very
specific role they're there to
immediately respond to the President or
the first lady and immediately bring
them back to the limousine for
protection in the event of a crisis
situation as you'll see we have agents
that are flanked on the left and right
hand sides who are there to address the
threats if anyone is to immediately come
over the barricade the supervisors are
in close proximity and they're there to
cover and evacuate these protectees and
get them to safety
he received in September 1975 President
Ford leaving a hotel in San Francisco
just after leaving the hotel president
fours walking towards his vehicle at the
same moment an assailant across the
street Sarah Jane more fired away the
Secret Service taking the emergency
action drill that they have trained for
took the president it covered and
evacuated him we're seeing the absolute
right things here being done by the
Secret Service agents the president is
here they're covering them they're
putting him down behind armor they're
trying to get him into the limo but a
fateful lesson was learned the limousine
door was not opened ever since this day
every time the president is near a
limousine near armor that door is open
because that's our safe haven another
lesson the Secret Service learned was
the day that President Reagan left the
Washington Hilton and was shot in the
moments that the assassination attempt
had occurred all the agents that you're
seeing here in here are starting to face
a protectee the lesson learned from
President Ford that we saw earlier this
limo door is open one of the key
elements of a Secret Service agent is
putting yourself between the threat and
the protectee here we saw our Secret
Service agent make themself big they
absorb the threat in this instance of
firearm this action alone saved the
president's life because it allowed for
President Reagan to be put right into
the limo we mitigated a potential loss
of life by instituting a policy because
of President Ford always to have the
limo door open imagine the tragic
scenario that we'd be in if this door
was not open at that time or the Secret
Service agent didn't react the way that
they did as we have seen the protective
model evolves over time the Secret
Service is always trying to evolve and
get better
they're reassessing every action that
they take on every single trip to ensure
a more holistic and secure environment
for the protectees one thing that hasn't
changed is that our protectees always
remain a target but how is the threat
changed what are the different tactics
that have used they've become more
dynamic because our mandate is
protection we have to put ourselves
between the threat and the
and that means that we have to stand up
tall when there's gunfire we have to go
address the threat head-on we have to
become the stop the barrier between that
threat whether it's a sharp edged weapon
a gun doesn't matter we have to stand in
between that threat and the protectee we
understand that it's just not normal to
want to put yourself in between a gun
and a protectee but there's a greater
calling here we have to think about what
we're protecting and what that mission
is